it's a regular notebook notebook
that has electronic options built
into it it's 2020 keep up
i don't even know i don't even know how
to comprehend this welcome to led live
we talk a lot about media on this show
but can media be used in a beneficial
way
in education find out on this episode of
led live
light exposing darkness hey everyone
thank you so much for tuning in to led
live today this is the show where we use
the light of christ
to expose the darkness found in media
and our culture today
and today we have my mom back with us
we're really excited to have her here
and she's going to help us with the
topic of education more specifically
media and education and we know that
schooling in 2020
looks a lot different now than previous
years you know every
more things are electronic online zoom
meetings and things like that
um what's the word for 2020
unprecedented
dumpster fire i don't survive
so we've noticed far you've noticed i
should say that students have been
struggling
more than ever with their education now
just because of how it's being delivered
to them so there are some ways that
we can help children in learning and in
education today so i'm excited for the
information that you have to share with
us
sure yeah well let me begin by bringing
to your
attention some data on media
uh by the way have you heard of george
barna from
the group oh yeah yeah yeah okay
so he as you know he is a christian
researcher
and he addresses mostly cultural trends
spiritual development
and church dynamics so based on his
studies
and the alignment of his results with
medical criteria he noted and i quote
that media exposure has become
america's most widespread serious
addiction definitely that's true
yeah so can you guess how many video
addicts there are in america
90 percent millions or 90 percent that's
huge
well according to the american medical
association
there are 19 million video game
addicts in america just video games
just video game and that covers all ages
from children all the way up to the
elderly
because addiction when it comes to video
addiction
there is no age limit yeah
that's right so when you hear the word
education what is the first word that
comes to your mind
school yeah books yeah
books learning you know for there you go
you got the word
what i was thinking of is learning
usually when we hear
education we think okay some learning is
going to take place
and since learning takes place in the
brain
and considering that the brain is the
control center of the body
and the frontal lobe occupies about
two-thirds of the brain
let's just briefly note its functions
so you have the frontal lobe which takes
up right from right behind your forehead
and it goes
all the way back it takes up about
two-thirds of your brain
it controls your spirituality morality
and the will then it controls reason
and conscience it also is in charge of
judgment
problem solving and decision making then
we have
memory and motor function that's
movement it controls your movement
it also controls prayer and worship and
discerning spiritual truth
then we have empathy and altruistic
altruistic
love so that's like where the character
sits because people who have lobotomies
like
their whole self changes that's right
because that's reasoning
your will conscience judgment all of
those things
so yeah now those include our most
important
intellectual faculties won't you agree
yeah
did you know that the bible talks about
the frontal lobe i've heard about it
you've heard about it yeah isaiah 1 18
said god says come let us reason
together reasoning happens in the
frontal lobe
and then in galatians 5 verses 22 and 23
where it talks about the fruit of the
spirit
the very last characteristic is
self-control
that's also monitored by the frontal
lobe
there's some old testament scriptures
that talk about keeping god's
commandments between your eyes
that's right that's right on the
frontlines of your eyes
that's the frontal lobe that's referring
to and then mark
12 31 when jesus was talking
about the second greatest commandment he
said
you shall love your neighbor as yourself
that's altruistic
love which also is controlled by the
frontal lobe
so here's another word that we hear
quite a bit of
entertainment when you hear
entertainment
what do you think of tv movies tv
dancing came to mind for some reason
dancing that's a form of entertainment
no no
just for some reason golf you know oh
well maybe maybe some norwood
tournament i don't i think i don't play
gold entertainment
well there are different forms of
entertainment
but theatrical style entertainment turns
off your frontal lobe
and so you may be wondering how does it
do that in a number of ways the the
rapid change
that happens in reference frames in
shows
and videos and that's about three
seconds every three seconds on average
the frame changes
that lulls the brain into an alpha
pattern
and that's a low brainwave frequency so
when the brain is in that frequency it
is in a highly suggest suggestible
state in other words it's in a
hypnotic state so that type of
entertainment when the frames are
changing so quickly
and that's why when you notice um when
children are watching
their cartoons and these other little
shows they have for them
they don't pay you any attention you may
be calling their name they don't even
hear you
because they have been hypnotized by the
show
so the conscious what happens then is
that the conscious thinking mind
is shut down and when you are
in a conscious thinking state your brain
actually is in beta wave
and that is more stable it's an alert
state so the entertainment theatrical
style entertainment
it gets rid of that i remember somebody
was saying that
uh when people drive from like nevada
to like arizona also so it's very like a
straight
and desert and they found a lot of
accidents
it feels like what happened is that in
death valley type
the area i don't know but it was just
like a straight
it's like why you i mean what happened
you know what happened
they fall asleep so they said the lines
and the roads because it's ripped
you know we talk about representing
repetition
so it's like so they go like a 80 miles
per hour so it's very fast
so that's the thing yeah i fell asleep
so i don't know that fits in that thing
but i just want to share that with you
it's possible
it's quite possible because it
definitely is affecting the alert state
of
they're no longer alert they're out of
that
issue i mean of course by the time you
go to sleep that's the delta wave
you know it's like you're almost flat so
now document there's a there's an
exception style
films they don't do that because
within a documentary someone an
interviewer is usually talking to people
interviewing people people take time to
think so you can't change a frames so
quickly you have to wait for them to
finish their thought
and formulating what they want to see
and speaking it
and so the frames can't they just can't
change so quickly
and by the way video games have a very
great hypnotic effect
and it's a greater effect than the
television shows
so video games are actually worse than
television why do you think that is
because it's like you're
so involved in it you're actually
becoming
it's almost like you are inside the game
because you're controlling
the character and well that's part of it
but it remember the video games go very
quickly
yeah so the frames are changing and the
quick change is allowing your brain
so your brain stops thinking and if you
stop thinking
that's why you get into and you just
become a part of the game because you're
no longer a conscious thinking person
wow is it also because in game you get
rewards so the brain get addicted
to that that's part of it that is part
of it
yes it raises up the dopamine and so you
get addicted
just like any other drug so it's an
electronic drug
you would see the movies back then you
know in the 50s 60s and 70s even the 80s
i mean
the what are you saying like right now
it's like every three three seconds
you know changing the scenes but back
then i mean if you watch one of the
videos like in the 80s like
man it's so boring like let's go back to
2000 or something you know talking about
the world boring that's the most popular
word that comes out of the lots of
children today
everything is boring because they're fed
this fast-moving
diet through the media that when they
come to sit in classes
it's boring if they're reading a book
everything is just boring to them
that's a big problem it also cuts
the attention span of children because
they can't pay attention they can't
focus on anything long enough
because it's so boring so now at the
same time
that the the shows and the video games
are shutting down the
temporal lobe and they're shutting down
your thinking process
they are designed deliberately to arouse
your emotions
so they evoke emotions of anger and
fear aggression lust sadness
and most of all amusement now when
you're in a state of amusement you're
not supposed to think
you're just supposed to be enjoying it
and just laugh at the whole thing
not think about it so just think okay
if you're not thinking and you're just
an emotional
melting pot then anxiety takes over and
all the emotions just kind of roll one
into the other
one of the things i have learned in
education is that anxious brains do not
learn
so if kids are immersed in these games
and they're so emotional and most of
these
games get they get you anxious because
you're trying to win
so they're not learning they're not
learning so
even though you have educational
videos if they're following the pattern
of the entertainment videos the
theatrical style
these kids are not really learning okay
so it's like they're not actively
learning but the fact that their
their reason is shut down
whatever is being put like an agenda
right so whatever the
form of media is trying to place in
their minds it happens more quickly and
seamlessly so in a sense they are
learning for instance um in habits as
they're playing the game and they get
angry quickly and reaction to things
they're like learning that habit
so there is being picked up but it may
not be the most beneficial thing right
so they're actually
learning to be more emotional in
response to
life events but in terms of the actual
knowledge or instruction that's being
taught it may appear that they're
learning because they may win the game
so they do it to get the immediate
response the
immediate gratification however there's
no long-term retention
remember it's a frontal lobe that is in
charge of
memory and so they won't retain they may
learn it enough to maybe even pass the
test that week
but they're not going to retain it for
the the year
or when they move to the next grade
which i guess is why it's so much of an
escape to go and play those games
because then they come out of it and
they're like i can't do life
you know i can't cope and that's why
some children deliberately and when i
worked in the school system
some kids deliberately didn't do their
work because they know
the teacher would tell them okay go over
to the computer
and do x y z assignment some of them
wanted to go to the computer because
they escaped
the boredom and the forced attention
that the instruction actually would um
require
it's interesting and they're on the
computer they they doing the game as far
as the teacher is concerned
they're doing something educational but
they're not really
learning so keeping all of this
discussion in mind
how can media possibly be used in a
beneficial way
in education today especially since we
have
such a mixture of how children are being
taught
we have some children still attending
schools
then we have others who are at home
doing remote learning fully and then you
have the blended type
where some of the children are going
into the classroom some days
and they are home other days how do we
really use media to help them
because you can't get away from it you
have to use media today
in education i guess we need to
encourage active learning
and using media instead of just
presenting a video
just like watch this video but encourage
them for example they can learn how to
code
in their computer like coding or
solve a problem with something that
not just that they have to do something
they have to engage
okay that's a key word there engage okay
and
it's how they engage with the media that
also makes a difference
yeah so like candy had said earlier
today there are lots of children who are
struggling in school and
those who struggle in school because
they learn differently from how
instruction is generally
i'm given they have been even more
challenged
during these times i i work as a speech
therapist with some kids at home
and as soon as the school shut down and
i had to work with the boy at home i saw
the difference right away
and it just kept getting worse every
month he was worse and he just
he regressed so much in the six months
he
he regressed probably like two years wow
and so i have seen it you know and i'm
sure he's not the only one i've read
lots of articles
where parents are complaining and
lamenting
that they don't know what to do with
their children they don't know how to
help them
because they're not getting the services
they need and their home
and they have to work they don't have
the time so
parents are in they're in a quandary
they don't know what to do
so today i want to share i want to share
some tools that allow these students to
access academic content
that they would otherwise not be able to
get to
and without the mind-numbing effects of
regular videos and adverse media
so we're going to talk about assistive
technology
so it's not entertainment technology
it's assistive technology
a sort of a lifeline to grade level
content
now educational research has shown that
assistive
technology works for these students
but there is a key component the right
tool has to be matched
with the right student right right you
know just like
yes just as we we all learn differently
yeah
and you have to figure out how you learn
and what what aspects
of education or what aspects of the
curriculum
you are good at and you kind of use your
strengths to help you manage your
weaknesses
so the same way when you're using media
the parent or the teacher whoever is
going to choose for that child
they need to know the child if you know
the child then you are able to choose
the right media
so whether it's the parent or it is the
teacher who's helping
the child with remote learning it
requires
thoughtful integration with the required
assignments
and careful implementation those two
are key the department of education even
agrees with that in 2
2017 they put out a statement
and this is what they said carefully
designed
and thoughtfully applied technology
can accelerate amplify
and expand the impact
of effective teaching practices notice
they said
effective teaching practices okay so
the person has to know how to teach in
order to
implement the technology and they
continued by saying
as technology enables new types of
learning experiences
okay so when implemented properly
appropriately assistive technology has
positive child outcomes regardless of
age
so from the smallest child the
kindergartner all the way
up to college level they can benefit
from assistive technology yeah i
remember
in was it the video game led live scotty
was presenting
on hospitals that have these
video game technologies that um people
who've had strokes and they need to
make new connections in their brains
here's somebody that has actually
um had a stroke and they're having her
play a little video game and
you guys can kind of see um what
how this is kind of working out so they
have a big sort of screen
in front of her and they have like these
butterflies that are coming and she's
supposed to like knock down the
butterflies
and just by that action alone that can
help her retrain herself to walk
used correctly these techniques can
really help
people across the board all ages the
whole point of the matter is
as you learn as you get new learning
experiences the brain is making
new pathways and new connections and
that's how learning
happens so now on the other hand
poor implementation can worsen the
learning gap of the students so it goes
both ways
it is crucial if you're going to use
media to benefit
education and learning you got to do it
right the first time you have to learn
how to do it
right or else you're going to be making
the situation worse
i wonder the schools knows about that
this information you're sharing because
it is important for them right like i'm
going to be teaching
you know the the class or something i
mean we need to get the right
software equipment you know well the bad
thing about like public school systems
they got
so many kids they're trying to teach and
she's saying you got to have
the specific tool for each kid
and they're just trying to find like one
thing let's find one thing that works
for all these kids
and that's why 20 of the kids usually
are left out
because they learn differently and
they're so wide
it's on a spectrum yeah so those are the
far end of the spectrum they're left out
because they just can't cope
and it's true they don't know so nothing
happens or they do know and they can't
afford it so nothing happens it's like
yeah so with the schools it's also on a
spectrum some of the educators the
administrators they do know
probably because they have children who
struggle so
they have a personal interest in it so
they know and they may make an effort
and you go all the way to the other end
where there are those who just don't
know
they don't care they say the child is
lazy and they just need to try harder
and they don't buy into well this child
is learning differently so
something needs to change in your
teaching it's not the child
they'll say oh he's just lazy if you
apply himself more you just
work harder he has no motivation and
they blame the child
instead of trying to change the teaching
style
or or um content and you know i
i have an aunt who i grew up with i grew
up with three parents
my father my mother and my father's
sister they always lived together all my
life and she was an
elementary school principal and she used
to tell us anything
worth doing is worth doing well
and that just stuck in my head so that
actually
fits in with the whole thing about
educational media
if you're going to do it you have to do
it well
so having alerted you to the media mind
landmines that are possible i caution
you to choose wisely
when you're choosing assistive
technology for your child's use
today i'm going to look at three types
of assistive technology
and these are not the video game like
types which turn off the child's frontal
lobe
just like the regular video games these
are different
so the options are the first option
we're going to look at is
physical tools so physical what do you
hear
physical tools like flash cards and
stuff yeah yeah so it's something
tangible that they can actually
feel it's not just something they're
zoned out looking at
so one is a cue ball there is this
mother whose daughter was born with a
hearing impairment
and she had to be fitted with a cochlear
implant while
still young the child was having
significant difficulty
in school both hearing her teacher and
her peers
at school and so the cue ball was given
to her in the school to help her
what is the cue wall it's a squishy ball
with a microphone
in it and it's designed to work with
practically any
audio setup this is good for quiet
reserved
non-responsive children it it gets them
engaged in
talking about a topic or an activity
because you know children love to hear
their own voices
and you can get really creative with its
use
it's it's sturdy and at the same time it
has a good
nice feel so here's a learning tip
research has shown that activity
enhances learning
movement increases learning so using the
cl
the cue ball it creates that movement
and while doing that
the children's brains are creating new
learning pathways
they're having fun and they're also
learning wow it's great that
everyone benefits because so there's a
microphone in the ball so as the ball is
being passed around the girl that has
the hearing difficulty can hear that
person as they're speaking
but it also helps the class because you
ever like in class the teacher will like
pass around the baton type of thing
so if i have the baton i'm speaking and
no one else speaks
that's anything yeah so it helps the
students with their listening skills
right and also promotes speech to
whoever
is holding the ball right yes and the
thing about this young girl is that
it didn't set her apart because
because she had the learning difficulty
she also had an fm
unit so the teacher had
the microphone around her her neck
when the teacher spoke the girl would
hear the teacher in her you know in her
receiver
but in the class when they when they had
class activities
what used to happen is as the other
children were speaking
she was just hearing a muffle of sound
there's sounds coming from everywhere
with the ball every child who spoke
she heard that child individually
because the child was speaking into that
mic
and the mic was hooked up into her audio
super cool man i like that
yeah so the same way it works for her
with the hearing impairment
it works for the other children because
each child that spoke heard themselves
speak because the room also had had
speakers
very interesting okay yeah so now that
that's the cue ball
the second tool
is called a boogie board
and it's by sink yeah you've seen that
one
it's a light and durable that's sort of
like a white
board yeah that you write on it doesn't
require instructions to use it's pretty
simple and straightforward
and what is written on it can be erased
or you can save it to a tablet or a
laptop
so that that's the nice thing about it
it can be used across
all areas all subject areas and you know
children like to
write and just the novelty
of the writing instrument it's not paper
it's not pin it's not that
boring flat thing in front of you they
can hold it in their hands so
it has that 3d effect and then they
write on it
you all you need is is
the pen and you can it comes with a pen
but you can get replacement pens from
staples yeah it you can even get a
highlighter pen
i guess the good thing about that is it
doesn't have internet and apps on it and
all that it's just like
a notebook type of thing yes
and whereas the front is nice and smooth
where you write the back is sort of
textured so they get a better grip when
they're holding it
and it's called the boogie board i mean
yeah yeah the booking board
so here's a learning tip research has
proved that
writing by hand activates larger
networks in the brain
than typing on the keyboard there's just
something that happens in the brain
when you write by and i heard it's gonna
you retain your
information better that's right that's
right because
it's increasing the the brain networks
we were just writing some little thank
you cards and stuff and i can tell
like man writing takes a lot of effort
now
i mean we we do so much of this and the
computers like
when i was growing up we wrote all the
time
in school and um you know just
with your friends or whatever letters to
our friends who are aware
i mean yeah a is like this instead of
like this you know
yeah my youngest daughter she is
learning memorize the verse in the
bibles
and she copies it and write down
metadata like maybe like two pages and
she'll see memorize it
so the other day i was like what are you
doing
so she figured out that she needs to do
that yeah that's awesome yeah so she's
like
because you know we were talking about
like how so cool you know we need to
memorize the word of god and and
she's the next day i mean she was
copying the whole thing i was like you
give me the bible say no it's the same
verse
and so i memorized i will stop i was
like oh that's cool
you're like 25 of them that's kind of
neat you know
that's awesome because she has realized
one way that she can memorize
yeah the quicker that students figure
out how they learn
the better it is for them because then
they just know what to do
and writing establishes pathways that
lead to a higher level
of information processing so writing is
like a teacher of mine used to say
think on paper you know when you write
something
out you have to be clear about what
you're writing
so until you get clarity you really
can't write the thing out properly
so it helps in all of those different
ways the boogie board
and there is another writing
tool that i really like i mean that's
like my favorite one and it's called a
rocket notebook
i've heard i've seen that you've seen
the rocket yeah yeah
this is an erasable notebook called the
rocket book
and i think i can do about 90 of the
digital note-taking on this
for between 25 and 30 bucks as i can
on this for a lot more
it's really awesome this one is an
erasable notebook now when it first came
out
to erase it you had to stick it in the
microwave but but they have
they have come a long way from that now
all you need is a damp cloth
it looks just like a regular notebook
spiral bound
five by eight in fact they're different
versions of it you also have the little
memory you can find
it yes now these
the both of these work with an app okay
so the boogie board has the sync app
that you you when you save you use that
app to save to
whatever your device is with the rocket
notebook
it has a series of icons on the inside
of the front cover and at the bottom of
each page
there are also those same icons so after
you
do your writing on the page like normal
with a pen a regular pen you'll go to
the bottom
of the the page and you do an x on the
icon for what you want to save it to
if you want to send an email to yourself
an email to your parent an email to your
teacher
you want to save it in evernote google
drive
yeah whatever wherever you want to save
it you choose and you put an
x and it will save it to that place so
this is like a digital
paper no no it's a regular paper it's a
regular notebook that has
electronic options built into it
and so you're fine it's not paper oh no
i'm not honest that's a good thing
you should have to put it in the
microwave it's 22. keep up
i don't even you used to have to stick
it in the microwave to erase
what you wrote on it it's not paper it's
like synthetic material yes it's a
synthetic material
so now what you can do is you wipe it
off with a damp cloth
now here's a here's a fun fact if you
wrote something and you erased it by
mistake
you can actually take it and put the
notebook in the freezer
and it will bring the note back but you
can only do that one time
it's not harry potter guys that's so
weird man
like i gotta see it yeah yeah make that
face right in the camera so i can
capture it
it's so weird
yeah and it has it has quite a lot of
options so you know how some students
they benefit from color coding
yeah so you can use regular dry
erase markers and color code
the books you can wipe it clean you can
wipe it clean with damp cloth
or you can wipe it you can if you use
the
are the markers then you use the dry
erase
eraser it sounds like a smart board
sort of sort of so now there are
a number of variations of these
notebooks so
children have choices and there are
adults that use them too
i'm planning and getting one of these
yeah
so if you want to if you want to learn
more about these physical tools
feel free to look down in the links in
the description box
they'll be there so our second tool
that can be used is audio response
there are already similar things that we
use
on our phones but for children the one
that i like is called vocaroo and the
vocaroo
is it's powerful for students like
children of dyslexia they are usually
pretty good speakers but they struggle
with spelling reading writing
so if they have when they have
assignments to do
they can choose to speak their
assignments
into vocaroo and it allows them
to give that voice response instead of
writing it down
and then the the child it's a website
so on the website there are a variety of
ways that
you can send your response to the
teacher or the parent whoever gave you
that assignment
and there's there are quite a few of
them
including facebook and whatsapp
and then you can also upload it to a
website or a blog you know all the kids
they make websites and
in high school so they can actually send
their their voice note or their response
it could be a written res
well it could be a story it could be
something lengthy and you can send it
and spread it that way
i love how the accessibility is kind of
spreading
not just with those who might be
physically incapable of doing things but
maybe
they have learning issues so just as a
blind person may have
the the speech on their phone so they
can hear a text message that comes in
now a child who may have trouble reading
can hear the text
and then respond to it verbally and send
it to their teacher and that may
increase their marks it's not really the
child who's dumb or
can't learn they have the answer they
just can't communicate it so that's a
great way to help them
that's right because um one of the
things that i have learned
is there are three kinds of reading you
have
the print book where you have the black
and white
the words on the page and you read it
then so that's eye reading because you
got to look at it
then there's air reading and that's what
you do when you're listening to audio
books
and then there's finger reading that's
what blind people do
when they're reading brain now if you
don't look down
on blind people for reading
braille with their fingers then why
would you look down
on the student who needs to listen to
the the information and speak it instead
of reading it with their eyes yeah
that's a good point i i remember my um
my brother he uh was a couple
one great ahead of me in school but uh
very intellectual with like sciences and
things like that
and and i was i was really good at math
but struggled in anything that i had to
read like if it was like lots of reading
i just didn't do as well until my
brother came up to me and he said you
know there's two types of
ways of looking at this information they
have the reading and then they have a
picture
if you learn to look off of the picture
you can understand what they're saying
and that concept totally revolutionized
my high school
days and i learned like biology and
science and all those things
from literally observing the pictures
and i'm very picture orientated as
opposed to
word orientated i see the picture i
remember it much better
and that may also be why you're so um
verbally
adapting what's the word adept yeah
yeah so the third the third
um tool that i'm going to talk about
today and there are lots of tools i just
chose three of them
because for brevity is digital
storytelling
you know the higher up you go in school
you start from probably first grade
you have to learn story structure you
have to know how to tell a story
you have to know about the setting and
the characters
and all the things that go with that so
there is
a website called storyboardvat
so it's storyboardthat.com it's a
platform and it allows students to tell
stories
using cartoons that's cool so
the all of the characters are there they
can pick the characters they can dress
them
they can choose their voices they can
tell their stories
and show understanding of story
structure
all they're just so creative so for the
child
who when when he or she sees a blank
page
their mind also goes blank this works
and you'd be surprised at how creative
children actually
are they just need to access
their knowledge in various ways
so when you facilitate all the children
then you can truly see what they can do
so that takes us to the end of those our
three tools
the first was the physical tools so we
looked at the cue ball
it looks at the boogie board and the
rocket notebook
the second was an audio response and the
third was digital
storytelling so the first thing that any
parent or teacher must do
if they're going to use that before
beginning to use
any of the educational media they have
to establish
guidelines for usage
okay the first is i'm just going to list
three of them
and for the others they will be
in a checklist a downloadable checklist
will be provided in the description
box so the first is when you're first
introducing
a method to a child technology to the
child you need to give that child
unlimited time to get familiar
to explore and to practice before
using it initially for the purpose you
got it
the second is that you need to set once
that
is over with and you're going to start
working you set a specific
time for tasks children need to know
what to expect so if you're going to do
math you say okay
we're going to use the boogie board
today and we're going to do 30 minutes
of math now
so the child knows what's coming and the
third
is you have to determine a specific
location
where you're going to keep the devices
so
whatever you're using for writing this
is the writing zone
this is the math zone this is the art
zone
so everything is clearly specified
and the child does not get confused they
know what to expect when they go to this
zone
what is expected of them when they go to
that zone or the other
i laugh because it's like treat the
child as you would want to be treated
type of thing
it's like we know that this is our
location to come to work it's from nine
to five and it's like
we like that structure we so we should
provide that for children
all we have to remember is children are
little people
they have they have thoughts and
feelings just like we do
some of them may not be able to
verbalize
what they're thinking or what they're
feeling others may
and so we have to pre-think yeah we have
to actually
contrive ways of helping our children
succeed and it doesn't matter how a
child
learns if we are able to help the child
figure out how they learn they will
take it away they will take it away once
they know how they learn
they will just be off into the
stratosphere
it's amazing when you hand a piece of
technology to a child i'm always
surprised at how
quickly they learn what it does right i
mean it's like my kids are showing me
things that happen on the iphone and i'm
just like
you you don't how do you you don't even
have one i don't know it does that
they just figure it out i call today's
kids clicker attitudes
click eraty kids they just seem to know
what to click and how to how to figure
things out
we have to remember that just as each
child accesses and processes
information in different ways each child
also approaches
and demonstrates their learning in
different ways
we need to facilitate that so when
learning opportunities
are offered in ways that are compatible
with how children access knowledge they
take
ownership of their learning and that is
demonstrated in
improvement in their academic
performance
wow possibilities are endless it seems
like and this is really encouraging and
so thank you so much for sharing and
if there is any idea that you have or
anything that you've
implemented in a child's life that has
helped them succeed in their education
this year please put that down in the
comments section below
so other people can benefit if you want
to know more
about helping struggling students excel
in school
stop failing and you stop being afraid
for them
and their future you can tune in to my
website where i do facebook lives every
sunday at three o'clock
everything that we've mentioned on the
show today the links to those will be
found in the description box below if
you like this video please like and
subscribe and share this to friends and
family
thank you so much for watching we'll see
you next week on led live
[Music]
do
you